ALEX GOUAILLARD: Well, thanks
to the organizer for having me
here.
I'm going to talk
to you a little bit
about the infrastructure part.
I'm Alex, the CTO of Temasys.
We're providing a few
services that I'm not
going to speak about today.
I'm just going to take you
guys through the painful path
we followed last year trying
to build up a first scalable
infrastructure.
So this is what I'm
going to speak about.
Most of the people start
from the reference code.
So I'm going to start
from there, too.
And there is a lot of reason
why you should do that.
Now, the reference code
is good for one use case,
but might not be
good for others.
So I'm going to put
disclaimer on that
and show how you
can do it better
and address the first
real pain, which
is going to be scalability.
There's a lot of things
on the infrastructure
of a good WebRTC solution
that are going to be left out
of this presentation because
it's only 20 minutes.
But I'm still going
to provide the list
at the end of the
point you might want
to look at before you
go into architecturing
such a solution for yourself.
All right, so the
reference code.
WebRTC is an API.
So APIs are difficult
to demonstrate.
There is a reference
implementation
at webrtc.org where a lot of
companies, including Mozilla,
Google, MIPS, Intel.
Vonage contributed too.
It has the existing pure
connection, all the APIs.
It has an iOS version.
It has an Android version
with all the wrapping,
so if you want to start
somewhere start there.
It's working.
And to be able to
play with it, there
is also a reference application
for you to use that.
As [? Sari ?] told you
before, WebRTC is just an API.
If you want a solution,
you need to make
a choice for the signaling.
You need to make a few choices.
You need to provide
a few servers.
And that's exactly
what appRTC does.
So this is the
drawing of appRTC.
You have a STUN server
provided by Google, by Mozilla,
depending on which browser
you connect to the website.
There is a separate web server
for the TURN management,
for the load balancing,
and geographically loading
for TURN.
There's a TURN
cluster, actually.
Then you have the web server
and the signaling server.
The advantage of the
appRTC is that it's
hosted by Google App Engine.
So it's very scalable.
You don't have to think
about how many instances.
They're already
taking care of that.
You don't think about
replicating the database
or things like that.
It's done for you.
So there is a few problems
about the reliability, though.
And that's mainly on
the signaling server.
So appRTC is here to implement
a very simple case which
is a one-to-one communication.
And within that scope, it
does the job very well.
And if you find a mistake
and you want to report a bug,
the first thing you're
going to be asked for
is to try to replicate
it with appRTC.
That's where the
maintenance job is done.
Now, one of the
problems, though,
is that the signaling server is
actually not a single signaling
server but it's leveraging what
is called the GAE Channel API.
And that is sometimes a
little bit problematic.
The access to the
database induce delays.
And up to our experiments.
The GAE Channel API
is sometimes not
reliable-- and more
than sometimes.
So if you're going to
multiparty for example,
the first thing people want to
do is to go from the one to one
to the multiparty.
And suddenly, there's a lot of
things that go unpredictable.
So this is a little
drawing of what
is happening behind the scene
just for a handshake, right?
So you have the caller and the
callee for a one-to-one call.
OK, the addLocalString,
createOffer,
setLocal-- that's the
API you have in WebRTC.
And in the middle, you
have a signaling server
exchanging a few signals, right?
That is very, very order
and timing sensitive.
So if you start adding delays
on one part or the other,
and you don't do that
exactly in order,
exactly like that, things
just don't go through, right?
The reference code, you
can make it reliable,
adding delays, adding
database here and there.
This is what is done in appRTC.
You have a cache for the message
waiting if a message arrives
out of order and
things like that.
But then the handshake is
stretched up to 10 seconds.
So we had a multiparty scalable
solution based on that one
point, but waiting 10
second for things to happen
is just not acceptable.
So let's go for a
little bit better.
As was mentioned
before, a lot of people
just drop that signaling
and go for something
that is Node.js based.
It's much more reliable.
It's much faster.
So you can achieve
handshake under one second
without a lot of effort
with almost all the SDK API
out there.
There's a huge ecosystem
of plug-ins and modules
and stuff you can put
on your node to actually
add very nice
feature very easily.
Now, the problem is you
lose the scalability
you had from Google App Engine,
and you lose the maintenance
as well.
So you can put the maintenance
on an API SDK vendor,
if that's the route you want.
But if you do it
yourself, you will
have to be very careful
about the level of test
and the security
you want to provide
with your infrastructure.
So let's address that.
What's the scalability
problem, really?
Most of the people
reviewed Node.js
and would go for a public
cloud, like let's say Amazon Web
Services, if only because
they're everywhere
in the world.
And if you want to address Asia,
as we're based in Singapore
and that's the fastest
growing market,
Amazon Web Services
is the only one
that will have 10 data
centers all across Asia.
Now, the problem with Amazon
Web Services, for example,
is they don't give you a
commitment on bandwidth.
They're going to tell you
low usage, medium usage,
or high usage.
So you start going there, and
you start doing benchmark,
and then you
realize very quickly
that there are unwritten rules.
The biggest and the
newest instances
will have preferential
access to the bandwidth.
And the big instances will
have their own network adapter,
so you can actually have
replicable bandwidth, right?
Otherwise, on the small
instances, one day
you have 50 gigabytes,
the day after you have 10.
You have the noisy
neighbor effect.
So you will so for the big
instances and the newest one.
The second problem is you
don't have Amazon Web Services
socket intensive
instances, right?
So they have CPU intensive.
They have memory intensive.
They don't tell you
anything about bandwidth.
What about socket intensive?
A signaling server
is something that
will have a lot of
sockets open-- and closed,
open and closed-- and they
don't have really an instance
that fit to that.
Most people will use
Socket.io for the transport
because it will provide
you web socket, which
is the best solution out
there when it's available
and implement or fall back
to XHR and other solutions
when it's not, right?
So it's completely transparent,
and it's fantastic.
The problem is it
doesn't scale across CPU.
So if you go for one of those
big instances like the 8XL
and you have 32
CPU, well, you're
going to use only one CPU.
So you get the
bandwidth, but you're
wasting most of your CPU power.
Horizontal scalability
is a problem.
Everybody that play
video games know that.
You have to connect to the
same server as your friend
if you want to play
with them, so there
is a limit that is per server.
What do you do when you want to
have people that are chatting
in the same room but spread
across different servers
on your infrastructure?
That's horizontal scalability.
And finally, Node
fails often, so you
need to find a way
to address that
and to handle the
downtime when you want
to upgrade your back
end, for example.
So let's go into that.
Socket.io look 0.9
scales using a store.
So for example, we
use Redis, and I
think that that's the best
way to achieve a low latency.
But the problem is the store
replicates the data object,
so then all the
instances of nodes
using that store will
try to do the same thing.
So you're not CPU scaling.
You just replicate the load on
every single one of your core.
So you do several
times the same thing.
So Socket.io 1.x specifically
addresses that problem.
It change the way
the store works.
It's going to use the same
store as an event bus.
So each instance run
independently of each other,
and it's only handling the
clients connected to them.
That being said, they still
only send to all the events,
so two clients can be
connected to separate instances
and still speak to each other
through the signaling server.
So it's Socket.io 1.0 solved the
horizontal scalability and CPU
scalability problem if you
have a Node.js problem.
The horizontal
scalability can even
be improved by using the
business, as you heard.
We use proxy load, but
everybody that has a website
and has a load is using that.
So just to mention,
you can also improve
by just putting a NGINX or
HA high-availability reverse
proxy in front of everything.
Node zombification.
So the problem with Node is
it's failing quite often.
And you have to
be careful and be
able to detect not only when
it fails to bring it back,
but also sometimes when you
have a new version that you
want to deploy in
your infrastructure,
you don't want to take the
infrastructure down and cut
existing conversation,
for example,
time for the deployment.
So there are a few Node
modules that are good for that.
There is a Node Cluster
API, which is nice.
There is forever.
Not forever, but
actually going to monitor
every instance of Node
running and bring them
back up if they fail or
terminate by themselves.
But there is a new
one which is called
PM2, which is even
better than that.
It does keep alive clustering
and load balancing at the OS
level, not at the instance
level-- log aggregation,
terminal monitoring,
and a lot of other magic
that's going to make your
life much, much, much easier.
So there are other
things to consider
when you think about a
WebRTC infrastructure,
even though the scalability is
really, really the pain point.
Scalability for the signaling
server like I presented to you
is one way to approach
it, but you're not
going to scale a media
server-- an MCU-- the same way.
Because it's going to
be bandwidth intensive,
because it's going
to be CPU intensive,
so every single piece
of your infrastructure
will have to have a
different way of addressing
the scalability
issue and you still
need to keep the entire
infrastructure coherent, right?
So that's where the
difficulty resides.
You want to be careful
about session management,
authentication, usage
payments, but there
are a lot of usual
solutions that
exist for that in the
ecosystem that you can take out
of the shells,
and you don't need
to make different for WebRTC.
Now if you really, really want
to go into the difficult part,
TURN server can be
difficult to load balance.
When you use appRTC, it's
done a very smart way behind
to put the secret
outside the website,
have security and load
balancing at the same time you
don't see it.
And the source code
for that has not
been made available, so be
careful for when you go out
of appRTC.
You will have to replicate that.
And MCUs are really
the things that
are going to make a
difference if you want
to have more people
in a given conference,
and they don't
scale the same way.
There it is.
[APPLAUSE]
I don't know if
we have time left.
But apparently, there
is nobody behind me,
so if anybody has
questions, they're welcome.
Questions?
Is the middleware to handle
TURN server load balancing
going to be made available?
JUSTIN UBERTI: Yeah, it
actually is available.
ALEX GOUAILLARD: The COE TURN?
JUSTIN UBERTI: Yeah, the
Compute Engine on Demand.
And I think that's
actually been open sourced.
I'll talk about that
more a little later
because I want to address--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ALEX GOUAILLARD: So Justin
Uberti, tech lead for Google.
JUSTIN UBERTI: A [INAUDIBLE]
walks into a bar--
[LAUGHTER]
Just responding to
the-- we have a thing
called-- it's Compute Engine
on Demand, which actually
is like a service that runs
on App Engine that spools up
TURN servers running on
Compute Engine on demand.
And we have that code.
It's actually open sourced.
I'll go find a link to
it so that the things
that-- the secret sauce
that Alex is referring to,
we can make it unsecret.
Alex also mentioned some
issues with the actual Channel
API and message delivery.
This has been a recurring
nightmare for us as well.
This stuff is all getting
gutted, burned with fire,
and rewritten so that it
is going to be actually
appropriately industrial
strength based on Memecache,
and we hope to have that soon.
I'll talk more about that later.
ALEX GOUAILLARD: All right.
And GAE API for mobile, so I
don't have to put a webview
with a hack on [INAUDIBLE]
to be able to--
AUDIENCE: We'll have the
chance to ask questions, later.
ALEX GOUAILLARD:
OK, fair enough.